et armelle au sud du pays les opérations
d'évacuation des derniers combattants
ukrainiens de mariupol je le disais dans
les titres à se poursuivre ce mercredi
selon volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien qui n'a pas précisé le nombre
de ses soldats moscou de son côté évoque
la reddition de ces combattants
retranché depuis des semaines dans l'
usine asos talent armelle il ya une
guerre de communication entre kiev et
moscou autour de ce qui se passe à
marioupol qu'est-ce qui attend
concrètement ces hommes d'abord ce sont
des combattants donc au niveau des
russes qui sont quand même ce qui en
cercle ce qu'ils vont être sortis
soit parce qu'ils se sont rendus soit
parce qu'ils sont blessés soit parce
qu'ensuite un moment donné et ils iront
s'extraire seront des prisonniers de
guerre là il peut pas y avoir de doute
pour le côté russe dans la mesure où en
plus comme il les amène du côté du
dombass donc chez les pro russe ce sera
de toute manière des hommes qui seront à
disposition pour eux pourquoi des
prisonniers de guerre parce que ce sont
des gens qui les ont combattues qui ont
montré qu'ils étaient armés qui savait
très bien se servir d'armes parce que
pour résister autant de temps il faut
être très aguerris et puis il faut avoir
un moral d'enfer alors c'est vrai que
les ukrainiens les ont beaucoup soutenu
le président azzedine ce qui les a
beaucoup soutenu on se demande
maintenant s'il va pas le justement leur
demander de ne pas hésiter à se rendront
par le raid encore de mille soldats
qu'ils seraient là ça sera important
pour les russes pourquoi parce que ça
leur permet d'aborder nouveaux chiffres
959 militaires craignant des sauveteurs
se sont rendus depuis lundi c'est ce
qu'indique en tout cas le ministère
russe de la défense oui parce que du
coup effectivement ils sortent au fur et
à mesure les russes pour eux ce qui est
prioritaire c'est d'avoir d'abord un
contingent de prisonniers avec lequel
vous pouvez ensuite jouer parce que vous
pouvez jouer d échange avec des
prisonniers chrétien ou dans des
négociations finales quand on est sur
des découpes territoriales etc on peut
mettre tout ça dans le même temps la
discussion la deuxième chose c'est de
savoir qui sont ces hommes parce
qu'effectivement ils sont très aguerris
donc qui est ce qu ils sont parqués
ont-ils été formés quelles sont les
armes dont il dispose et puis évidemment
pour vladimir poutine de mettre la main
sur ces fameux miliciens du bataillon
azoff alors il ne sont pas tous mini
siens du bataillon azoff mais ce
bataillon est réputé effectivement pour
avoir des personnes qui sont pro nazi
est donc de montrer que du coup il a
engagé effectivement son combat dans le
combat ce parce qu'il y avait des
combattants de cet acabit la merci
beaucoup arman charrier pour cet
éclairage et